are you supposed to include a picture in
the CV or not and here I'd say it really
depends probably most on the region
where you apply to so I'd R you want the
Anglo-Saxon country so UK also the US
and so on I'd say it's rather unusual to
include it for of course discrimination
reasons you don't want CVS to be
assessed based on the looks of a person
for instance personally or my standard
CVR don't have a picture included of
course with the nice one page format
that I would recommend you to use in
general the picture takes a lot of space
often doesn't integrate that nicely on
the layout so if you can I'll probably
try to get away with not including it on
OCB